[Music]
I'm Mike Sadowski with Chet's cleaning
and we are out of Madison Heights
Michigan
and we clean just about everything
except for walls and windows today we're
going to be cleaning a dirty boat cover
[Music]
is just to keep the inside of the boat
not looking like the cover did so that
way the cover takes the brunt of the
elements rather than the boat
the material or the boat cover is a
Sunbrella material it's a solution dyed
acrylic so it has great stain resist
properties and it's pretty friendly for
the sun which is how it can survive out
there this one was primarily animal
issues flying overhead and uh some mold
that was built up from use I would guess
it was probably about five years out in
the elements
[Music]
the chemicals that we use it's called
dot there's a Dye floor granules in
there which is a chlorine and then there
is a surfactant so a detergent in there
allows us to get the soil off of all of
the molded mildew that is very chemical
friendly in terms of it's not going to
burn my skin at all it's virtually
odorless we use dual time to allow the
solution to break down any of the soils
mold mildew that's in there needs at
least a half an hour but I can let it
sit overnight at times
once that's had time to do what it needs
to do we go ahead and use agitation so a
scrub brush either by hand or mechanical
the yellow machine is called a cymax
it's an orbital scrubber so the scrub
pads at the bottom are just going in a
circular motion while the head turns in
a different direction what it's doing is
pulling apart the fiber slightly the way
they're woven and it allows the soil and
embedded mold and mildew to release a
little bit easier rather than still
being tightened welded with the fibers
foreign
water is what really breaks apart
everything that's down in there it's a
mild detergent that we use in rug
washing that is going through the power
washing gun so it's not just water and
soap and water coming out at the same
time
[Music]
I'm using the broom to push water off of
the boat cover a lot of times whether
it's the boat cover or rugs it's very
hard to see staining that's remaining
when the water is puddled on there so
I'm just pushing it off so that way I'm
able to see what's going on and make
sure that I didn't miss any areas while
I was power washing
the bath that it goes into I was just
using it to help rinse out all of the
detergent and the products that I had
put onto the boat cover because whatever
I use I want to make sure I get off
[Music]
if I put it through our rinse Winger so
that was just squeegeing out some of the
water and hitting it with another high
pressure system to get another power
washing job going through and making
sure I was getting it as clean as
possible from there we went ahead and
hung it and dried it with bow covers I
typically don't get them when they look
clean and wear rugs and upholstery I
would tell you it should be cleaned
regularly no matter what the appearance
well covers I go a little bit different
they are cleaned as needed if it gets
real bad and you want it clean that
would be the time if it's a generic
cover it might not even be worth
cleaning you just let it live its life
and replace it other times they might
outweigh the benefit of trying to find
material and get a new one made and just
have it cleaned up buy them a few more
years the biggest thing that I've ran
into whether it's from sun damage or
aggressive cleaning you actually cause
that Sunbrella to not become as
repellent and Sunbrella does sell a
product to reapply that repellency or
the protective to it so depending on the
scenario people to look to get that done
also to make sure it stays in good shape